[Music]
naked Marco well officially become a
royal in 73 days that while we know her
life as commoner is officially over that
clearly hasn't stopped makin from
enjoying the simple life we've just been
here for three months but the American
girl is becoming a true Londoner hitting
hot spots like the hippie curry burners
tavern the cozy restaurant in the London
edition hotel is also a fake George and
Amal I wouldn't blessed with a lot of
hair
oh yeah we're obsessed over how she
Styles those luscious locks and Megan
has been keeping her complexion glowing
with visits to top London skin guru
Nicola Joss for a luxury facial that
cost three hundred and forty seven
dollars her specialty
a deep face massage - really good to
give you that high cheekbones megan is
living with Harry and knighting him
cottage on the grounds of Kensington
Palace but she sometimes runs her own
errands the Daily Mail calm spotted her
under a baseball cap making a quick trip
to Whole Foods and when it's time for a
girls night out with her friends the
future royal drops by the brown cow pub
owned by a friend of Harry's some of the
house favorites a killer burger Bloody
Marys and a chocolate mousse laughs were
there haven't
[Music]